You’re a pizza delivery person for a company
we’re not at liberty to name.
It may seem like a thankless job, but you’re
part of the thin crust between satisfaction
and starvation for people who really don’t
feel like cooking or going out tonight.
You’re a tried and true pizza veteran.
You’ve seen a lot on the job - from people
who tried to rob you on their own doorsteps,
to one guy who tried to tip you with a clearly
fake Rolex - but you haven’t seen anything
like the insanity you’re about to encounter
tonight.
That’s because you’re about to get sick.
Really, really sick.
And we know there’s probably a lot of diseases
you’d rather not catch, but trust us, no
disease bites quite like SCP-3760.
But back to you.
You’re parked on the saddle of your prized
bicycle, pedaling for your life, the biggest
order you’ve ever delivered strapped to
the cargo rack behind you - eight large meat-feast
pizzas.
You figure you’re heading towards the most
hopping, or at least the hungriest party in
the city, and despite the frustration of needing
to ferry this hot, cheesy nightmare to its
destination, parties have historically been
pretty good tippers.
Little do you know, your prized customer is
about to give you much more than just a tip.
You pull up outside their ground level apartment
and park your bike.
There’s no music coming from the apartment
you’re heading to.
Strange.
You pick up your precious cargo and trudge
towards the door, barely managing to ring
the bell with your spare pinky.
The door swings open instantly, as though
the occupant was just standing behind it the
whole time, waiting for you.
When the door opens, you’re not sure what
to make of what you see inside.
There isn’t a party.
There doesn’t even seem to be a group.
Just one person, standing there and staring
at you, and something about this person is
just...wrong.
His skin seems to be an oddly unnatural color.
It has a slightly gray hue, like it’s rotting,
and you see that the stranger’s shirt is
torn in several places.
You’re trying your best to remain professional
and not stare, but you can’t help but notice
that whatever is under these tears doesn’t
look like skin.
It’s almost like there are holes all over
his body underneath the shirt - big, gaping
holes.
And are those…
You’re cut off when he takes the pile of
pizzas from you, and shoves what was once
a handful of dollars into your palm.
They seem torn up, and worst of all, wet.
You look past your strange customer, and see
that his apartment looks just as shoddy as
he does.
There’s stuffing torn from the couch.
Huge tears in the curtains.
What you could swear are scratch or bite marks
on some of the wooden furniture.
This man clearly needed his pizza.
As you begin to step away, happy to just be
rid of this freaky situation, you do something
that you’ll live to regret.
Just for a moment, you lock eyes with the
customer.
There’s something about them that makes
you feel sick.
They’re wet and black - more like a doll’s
eyes than anything that should belong to a
human.
Just that one instant of contact is enough
to chill your bones, and according to some
theories around SCP-3760, it may have been
the moment of your infection.
As the stranger closes the door in your face,
presumably to eat his obscene number of pizzas,
you stumble back to your bicycle, letting
your torn up, gooey tip blow away in the wind.
Getting out of this place is rewarding enough.
But you can’t chase the thoughts of the
stranger out of your mind.
Was he sick?
Was he even human?
These are the thoughts swimming through your
head as you cycle back to the restaurant.
You’re so preoccupied, you don’t even
notice the truck speeding towards you.
You get sideswiped, destroying your bike and
throwing you through the air.
You can feel the snap of your arm breaking
as you land.
It’s a horrible feeling to go along with
the horrible noise.
And as you fade from consciousness, the last
thought in your mind is the black, soulless
eyes of the customer.
When you wake up, you find that you’re in
a hospital bed with your arm in a cast.
The doctors tell you that you’re phenomenally
lucky to be alive given the severity of the
crash.
The doctor says that you’re dealing with
a compound fracture in your right arm, as
well as some nasty cuts that required stitches,
but otherwise you’re fine.
The hospital insists that you at least stay
the night though, and you oblige, but that
night you find it’s difficult to sleep.
Partly because of the pain, but mostly because
of an extremely strange sound coming from
inside the cast around your arm.
It’s a scraping noise, like something sharp
scratching at the interior.
You figure it must just be some strange side
effect of the pain meds - you’re not going
to let worry eat you up inside.
Something else will be doing that soon enough.
You’re discharged from the hospital the
next day and told that you should be fine
in a couple months, as though that’s some
kind of consolation.
You try to carry on with your daily life,
as much as you can with one arm out of commission,
but that awful crunching noise from inside
your cast persists.
You even start to become paranoid that some
sort of insect is trapped inside, or worse,
a swarm of insects.
But you aren’t left with that uncertainty
for long.
By the next morning, your cast has fallen
off.
Well, not “fallen”, per se.
A more accurate description would be that
it was chewed off from the inside.
And not by something trapped in there with
your arm, but by your arm itself.
When you finally see it, it doesn’t even
look like an arm anymore: The flesh has turned
gray.
That same sickly gray of the customer’s
skin, the night of your accident.
But worse still: From the top of the hand
down to the base of the forearm, your entire
arm is split open into a fang-lined, chattering
mouth.
When you’ve gotten over the initial horror
of seeing the mutations that have taken hold
of your arm, you notice something about the
teeth in the second mouth: They’re nothing
like human teeth, they’re vicious, jagged
triangles, each one like a dagger.
These are unmistakably shark’s teeth.
You give yourself the luxury of having a good
scream - After all, what else are you supposed
to do after you find your arm has turned into
some kind of fleshy shark mutant.
You notice that you can hardly even feel the
snapping of its jaws, like it isn’t even
really a part of you.
And as much as you try to tense and release
what used to be the tendons in your forearm,
there is no change.
For all intents and purposes, that limb is
no longer yours, it just happens to be attached
to you.
Not only that, but it’s always very, very
hungry, as quickly became evident from the
fact it made such short work of the cast that’d
been containing it not long ago.
You can see that the graying flesh is beginning
to spread from your forearm to your bicep.
It’s almost like, little by little, your
tissue is being switched.
Somehow, you’re innately aware that if you
don’t feed your arm, it’ll get even worse.
Suddenly, everything about the strange customer
from the night of the accident makes sense:
He had whatever you have now, only worse.
He was just hoping that the pizzas would keep
the beast at bay, and you very much hope the
contents of your fridge will do the same.
Wasting no time, you grab some processed ham
and raw chicken - you’re not an idiot, you
know that if this thing is anything like a
real shark, it’s only going to be interested
in meat.
But when you shove the processed meat into
the nibbling maw in your forearm, you notice
that it seems to spit the food out.
Something tells you that your offering was
too… dead.
Now, you’re really afraid.
Will this thing want live prey?
Will that be the only way to stop it from
taking the rest of your arm, or even more?
The thought terrifies you.
It’s like being Venom, except you don’t
even get a new alien friend or any cool superpowers
for your trouble.
But you’re smart; you’re resourceful.
You don’t intend to let this thing take
over your life without a fight, and you’ve
always believed what GI Joe taught you: Knowing
is half the battle.
Sadly, doing an internet search for “My
injury is somehow mutating into a shark, how
do I stop this” didn’t do much good.
And you don't want to go to a doctor, because
part of you expects to be immediately shipped
off to the nearest circus or military research
lab.
Instead, you throw on a thick leather jacket
that you hope your new shark-arm will take
a while to eat through, and head to the library
of the nearest medical college.
If anywhere has sources on the most obscure
of medical problems, this would be the place.
And after hours of searching through index
cards, you find it - what seems to be the
one and only source on this ludicrous topic
in the thousands and thousands of books: A
series of journal entries made by Dr. Keith
Woodward, Ship's Medical Officer aboard the
USS Kirby, circa 1922.
Even the library’s indexing system prefaces
the source with a disclaimer that it’s likely
25% quackery and 75% ocean madness, but that
doesn’t deter you.
Any port in a storm.
Dr. Woodward told the horrifying tale of the
USS Kirby’s collapse due to a sudden and
unexplainable contagion.
It began with the infection of a sailor on
the ship named Willis Riggs, who’d fallen
overboard and had his foot partially eaten
by a shark.
Much like your arm, the man’s foot slowly
became the ravenous, all-devouring mouth of
a shark itself.
Little by little, it spread to other crew
members through unknown means.
Any injuries sustained by the crew didn’t
heal like normal, but instead became this
vicious, living shark tissue.
Soon, these ever-hungry new mouths led them
to eat each other, and then themselves, from
inside out.
Even after the humans they once were could
be considered long dead, those hungry jaws
kept snapping.
There was no cure.
There was no solution.
Everyone on the boat was recorded as having
mysteriously died at sea.
That is the curse of SCP-3760.
As if on cue, you look down to see that the
shark mouth in your arm has chewed through
the leather of your sleeve like it’s nothing.
It’s hungry, and nothing will satiate it.
But perhaps some sacrifices need to be made
if you want to stop it from getting worse…
Just as the thought crosses your mind, a needle
full of sedative is injected into your neck.
Everything goes dark very quickly, and when
you wake up, you’re in a clean, clinical
white room.
You’re now officially under containment
by the SCP Foundation, not that you’ll know
that any time soon.
This may seem like the cavalry has arrived,
but sadly for your sake, they have no interest
in curing you.
They’re just eager to gather more data on
how your condition progresses.
SCP-3760 exists as a latent infection in well
over half of humanity, but its horrific, mutating
effects are activated in only a relative few.
There have only been 2,785 recorded cases
of SCP-3760 activity observed between 1958
and 2016.
This is thanks to the Foundation’s secret
weapon against the shark mutation menace - Subliminal
Memetic Agent Kappa/Omicron - or "SMA-K/O"
- a widely distributed memetic agent that
suppresses the symptoms of infection in most
people.
Not that this will provide much comfort to
you, as you join the almost 3,000 others who
have been infected and you are doomed to slowly
turn into an abomination in your containment
chamber.
If it’s any consolation, you may not see
the truly advanced stages of the disease.
The most common cause of death among the afflicted
is being eaten by their own ravenous shark
mouths long before it changes your entire
body.
Actually, come to think of it, that’s not
much of a consolation at all.
But hey, when it comes to anomalous mutations,
we’re sad to report that there’s rarely
a happy ending in store for those afflicted,
and SCP-3760 is no exception to the rule.
Now check out “SCP-4205 - In The Eyes of
the Beholder” and “SCP-610 - The Flesh
That Hates” for more anomalous infections
you really don’t want to catch!